bonjour olivier nora et votre domicile
si vous connaissez pas vous allez hérité
le magnifique appartement qui comprend
pas le perdre fait en aparté vous en
voulez pas moi je vais habiter ici
nous ce qu'on veut c'est revendre on est
d'accord je suis triste
pour le frigo j'ai vu qu'il y avait
quatre étages donc on met nos nombre de
sujets on n'est pas aux colons si on
fait des règles c'est pour y souscrire
totalement sinon dès demain c'est à gaza
au bout d'un moment on n'est pas au souk
non plus pardon vous alimentez tellement
cliché coirier ou de madame je marche
sur l'eau et je suis jamais cas car tu
fermes ta gueule hockey
comment vont tes soeurs demi soeur il y
en a une qui pose dans la mode
je vais essayer rien dire sur la french
manucure de la fusée les deuxièmes de la
revue elle occupe à ce concept
interro surprise la bauge et les styles
et s'habitue voit comme ces nanas qui
mettait chose avec des talons en vrai
c'est moche et comme a besoin la mode
beau c'est beau on n'a rien en commun
elles vont vite s'en rendre compte
tu sors fois qu'il est médecin on s'est
rencontré le matin où j'ai fait ma
coloscopie une ça veut dire qu'il a déjà
vus contre bâle ah non pour les mecs
constat qui on veut mais dans nos champs
enfin on n'est pas des animaux les
hommes c'est comme une théière petite
tête au ventre et que toujours ouverts
moment ya un problème avec la partie
serait qu'on avait rien à se dire que je
n'ai pas du tout le monde revient
toujours pas du moment mais ça n'empêche
pas qu'on peut se battre ensemble
moi parfois je me demande qu'est ce que
ferait rien à ma personne
tu as ta maman c'est que le vent de
nouveaux cerveaux les fermes ta gueule
c'est juste mais règle
non
jusque-là ça coûte de manhattan
ben tu vois ses fils est la seule
famille que j'ai voilà ça va t'en à
traiter une extrémiste et l'autre deux
coups tout à l'heure c'est bon bah oui
mais ça c'est pas raciste mais c'est
raciste non c'est bon d'avoir un
carrosse voilà bah la race des poufs